Hey California with my ID a four out of
ten minutes mm a trick up my new show
you today is a 40 degree variation I
learned from some Irish burglars I was
traveling around Europe and in the Mafia
Niall
thanks.thanks food trick and team fat
Wars but it kind of looks like this
four to three is a basic three ball side
swaddle the fours are thrown up from one
hand and land back in that same hand the
twos are treated as a little hold and
the threes bounce back and forth between
hand often it helps to use a different
color fall as your three in your four to
three pattern here you can see I'm using
a fairly large grapefruit take time to
notice the two in your four to three
pattern shake it around for a little
extra emphasis once you recognize when
the two occurs in your four to three
pattern you can move it up and down left
and right or any direction you might
want to the first drill for building up
to the cross-arm 4 to 3 is taking the
two I'm placing it under the other arm
and I'm going to call this cross arm
the second drill you can do to build up
to the cross-arm 4 to 3 is to take the 2
and to put it over the other arm once
you're comfortable with your column 43
and 43 and you're come from recognizing
one that too is you can begin to learn
the cross on 43 but in order to do that
we're going to begin with two bolts in
this first drill your throw the two from
a cross arm position make sure that you
adjust the height of your floors
accordingly to adjust for the time
needed to reach over and throw that two
and catch it back in the same hand
in this second drill the two will be
caught cross on this means that you will
need to throw a little toss and then get
your hand over there to catch it with
the same hand that you threw it with
once you have those first two drills
solid you can begin working on
three-ball versions of those just as you
can see here while I'm doing it make
sure to adjust the height of your fours
so you can catch those twos in the other
version of the cross arm four to three
the two is now caught cross arm instead
of throwing cross over once you can do
crop our 40-degree both weight or even
before is a wide variety important to
variation due to time and all that the
bat is controlling the two and that was
actually the goal of the video for this
there's some things you could actually
do with the tube you can make this drop
you can make it around the body throw
throwing more on the body you can go the
other way the two can also be a drops on
the legs super crazy and even stuff
there could be a wide variety of things
you can do with the tube so go on
thanks for watching my tutorial video
the IJA video competition thanks for
watching rate this video subscribe
whatever thank you
Hey